so I've got a date tonight I founded on
mobsters only dating comm and I'm so
excited
but he's the problem I don't have
anything nice to wear I know it's been
quite a while since you guys have seen
me
alright it's 5 o'clock so I've got a
couple of hours before my date so the
first thing that I'm going to get is
some new shoes do you have any red shoes
probably about seven and a half I think
in u.s. sizes Wow those are fantastic
[Music]
they won't approve yes
I have a date tonight so I gotta get
shoes told me that his name's Mary but
I'm afraid because after I looked at his
photo I think she probably doesn't look
like this because he looks really good
it's quite you know it looks that the
bosses are actually not read until
they're boiled they feel waterproof
because I'm just worried if I go back to
the sea that they're not gonna hold up I
want to show you my man weights you
can't go anywhere I've gotta get it out
of here like it's gonna work out
fantastic I've got to get my money
I hope it's it's good here
thank you so much
it's crazy to me because Lord look at
that man
and look at mine
I don't have to listen to that that's
not something that I understand so I
think I might need some lipstick for
tonight see here
these are expensive lipsticks
do you have a ready to match my
exoskeleton
things like this one looks pretty good
[Music]
okay do you think I should dance with
this bus
thank you so much thank you
maybe let's take a look at this red -
imagine my balding perfectly
oh no my aunt Anna Allah I thought some
things are feeling weird feel so silly
because I can't wearing normal hat
because then it covers up my eyes see
now it's waterproof or water-resistant
up to like I think 50 meters just
fantastic but I dive a lot deeper than
that
okay my name is Libby by the way hello
thank you so much you know I'm really
good at editing but I'm snow cuz I've
got like these things Thank You 7oi
stood a swim have a nice have a swimming
day
thank you Steve always have red
sunglasses
ironic isn't it
[Music]
yeah what is it yelling it was listed
phrasal Thank You photos do you see more
shoes
in water ski do you think this is a good
tinder shop for my profile I don't use
hit anymore
all these lobsters only dating college
it's $49 a month
anyway can you fix more in Toyama I
think it's broken
I knew that's why my senses are all
messed up this is a week it's broken
Oh fix him thanks a lot see oh how I
feel
well no what are these for I'm meeting
my cellphone nippy Libby I'm just you
know swimming out here just see what I
can see I just want these shoes today -
yes I am
is that bad yes I thought so
oh you think so it doesn't look like
enemy it's seven twelve or I've been
shopping all evening I haven't even put
on my lipstick yet
I'm hoping that can get a table at this
restaurant this is a falling dining
establishment I'm pretty sure that
you'll be quite impressed with my choice
there's candles on the table so that's
how you know it's fancy
twice on the table for two
thank you up and boy I'm ready for more
date I'm so nervous I hope he shows up
Oh
I said anything's any longer
[Applause]
[Music]
but waiting for a date but I don't know
not here yet but I'll start with a wine
of these names say or did my date
his name's Mary I ordered him one of
these as well and not sure what his
drink of choices because on his profile
it says he does not like hot water so I
said no tea for you Mary
hi Larry its newbie I was just wondering
if you're gonna make it because I'm 400
and I haven't swimming all day and I'm
quite parched
I ordered you a drink I can order you
some food as well so when you get here
you can eat
[Music]
call me back please it's a nippy you've
got it say that already we had a date
tonight I'm in Travis - Travis here
Travis Lee in Santa Monica it's my
father Pierre so you can just swim right
on up there's a valley for you I'll just
please know I'd love some bread thank
you I just got some bread I don't know
if you're I don't know didn't say on
your profile never I'll see you soon
please please show up bye
thank you so much thank you thank you
I'm not gonna wait for legs eat more
bread I'm going to see the dog
do you guys have lobster bisque by the
tracks no do anything lobster phix okay
that's probably better I think I'll do
the it's the rigatoni travel
the broccoli
- and I did everything right
[Music]
she didn't show up Larry
hey Larry I hope you have a fun time
wherever you are but it's not with me
it's not me
I don't ever wanna feel like a chick
everything was perfect I even knew space
to to make myself a little beautiful
sure that we have like more than one two
and you broke all of them there might be
felt so I know I skipped health class
when I was in school
this is quite good there on the upside
I'll get two meals Larry this one please
together we cry
[Music]
I don't ever wanna feel I gotta take me
to the place I know